We'd like to consider
a system of particles.
Let's say we have object one.
We'll call this the
j-th object, object n.
And somewhere in this system of
particles is a center of mass.
Now, we know that
the external force
is causing the momentum
of the system to change,
and what we'd now
like to show is
that we can reduce
this system to
an effective single particle.
The way we'll do that is recall
that the momentum of the system
is given by the sum of
the individual momentums.
We'll call that the
j-th particle where
we're summing j from 1 to n.
And that's the sum
of the momentums
of the various particles.
Now when you
differentiate the momentum
of the system with
respect to time,
we're just differentiating
the velocity.
And so that becomes
the acceleration
of the j-th particle.
Now we saw when we
define the center of mass
that the acceleration
of the center
of mass times the total
mass of the system
was equal to the sum of mj aj.
j goes from 1 to n.
So we see that
another way to think
about how the momentum of the
system of particles is changing
is simply the total mass
times the acceleration
of the center of mass.
And our combination of
Newton's second and third law
now becomes that only
the external forces
cause the momentum of the
system to change so that's
equal to the total mass times
the acceleration of the center
of mass.
Now what does this
equation really mean?
So let's draw our
pictures again.
Here's our system.
We have particles 1, et cetera.
That's the j-th
particle, n particles.
And in here is the
center of mass.
Now I'm going to outline
my system like this
and what this
equation is telling
us is that we can just focus
by putting all of the mass
and total at the center of mass.
And that center of
mass is going to move
according to some trajectory.
And all we have
to think about is
this is a point particle
of total mass m, m total.
So what we've done is we've
done a very important reduction.
We've taken a complicated
system of particles
and reduced it to a
single point particle
of total mass m located at cm.
And the dynamics of
that total particle
is if there is external
force acting on this system,
we place this external
force at the center of mass.
And now we can calculate
the acceleration
of the center of mass is just
that external force divided
by the total mass.
And that's how we can reduce
this complicated system
of particles to a translational
motion of the center of mass.
Now we still cannot describe
the individual interactions
in the system, but we're not
trying to do that anymore.
We're not trying to trace
how each particle moves.
We're just looking at as our
system is a point particle
and talking about how
that point-like object is
translating the space.
And this is a powerful
tool that we use again
and again and again.